I Frankenstein I don't care i
Frankenstein stars aaron eckhart as the
character of frankenstein and he runs
into this group of gargoyles and this
leader of the gargoyle starts calling
him adam because she feels that he has
something in him that is similar to
humanity he then learns of this war
going on between the gargoyles and these
creatures that are coming from the
underworld and the big evil leader of
all these guys is Bill Nye it's not that
one
wow this is a bad movie and it's too bad
because the writer director of this
movie stuart beattie wrote one of my
favorite movies of all time collateral
but besides collateral he hasn't really
done a movie as good as that film but
this movie is written and directed by
him and my word this is a trainwreck
let's just start with a couple positives
that I can think of for one aaron
eckhart is trying he's trying in the
role of Frankenstein he's giving it his
all I feel for him in every single shot
because I really like this actor is a
very good actor he's given great
performances in the past in movies like
Erin Brockovich thank you for smoking
the Dark Knight the guy can act
here he is saddled with an absolutely
horrible role in a terrible movie and I
don't know why he even picked this
script I mean everything about it just
feels so incredibly sci-fi channel movie
of the week another positive is that the
director did not overuse shaky-cam
or quick cutting he did a lot of wide
takes of action which was really cool
and I like the fact that he did that
Bill Nye is really relishing the role
you know he's got that Davy Jones thing
going you cannot save mankind
nothing can stop their demise and that's
all I can think of this movie is
absolute crap the CGI is incredibly bad
at times there were times where certain
gargoyles are on the screen and they
were all flapping their wings and I was
reminded of Birdemic have you ever seen
Birdemic the effects are better than
Birdemic I'm aware that I'm talking
about the way the wings are flapping so
fast and fake it looked so incredibly
unrealistic it took me out of the movie
almost every single time one of these
things is on screen now of course in one
of these movies you have to have a girl
right some sort of love interest well
let's have a couple four scenes or
Frankenstein's with this blonde chick
who's this scientist who's trying to
resuscitate rats by using electricity
and then the leader of the underworld
bill
nice characters like you I like that
because I want to resuscitate a whole
bunch of my old dead army so that we can
fight against these gargoyles let's use
this woman actually no Frankenstein you
got to go and protect that woman because
of that Oh guess what
she learns of this war between gargoyles
and demons from the underworld and that
Frankenstein actually exists guess what
she accepts it with a completely
straight face in like a minute
not a single essence of wow I'm
surprised there's some sort of
mythological war between creatures that
I never knew ever existed and I've heard
about from fairy tales my entire life
but that's okay because I'm currently
electrocuting a rat at home trying to
resuscitate it because that's what I do
with my spare time so I guess it's
possible the Frankenstein might exist
she doesn't even have an ounce of
surprise by all of this I'd be like I'd
be freaking shaking man I'd be like what
if there's an immortal creature in front
of me and there's gargoyles everywhere
let's go if she's just like look at this
gargoyles oh that's great this movie
just felt like it started and then ended
and absolutely nothing happened not an
ounce of character development nothing
really of any importance happened even
though everyone on screen is acting like
everything is so important because you
don't give a crap about anyone in this
movie the way this film was directed it
is paced so poorly big scenes that are
supposed to feel big don't feel big at
all then all of a sudden we're in
another huge scene and another huge
scene there's gargles flying everywhere
and you're supposed to care but you
don't because this movie is directed and
written so incredibly poorly the makeup
is so cheesy I was laughing half the
time anyone came on screen with their
monster faces it was pretty hilarious
actually there is an aspect to this
movie where you can actually watch it
and laugh at how bad it is but
unfortunately there isn't enough funny
stuff in it to warrant the so bad that
it's good title this is just an awful
movie I Frankenstein I'm going to have
to give you a d-minus simply because
Aaron Eckhart was trying a couple of the
fight scenes looked like they were
actually doing choreography for once
which was great
besides that this movie is an absolute
atrocity and a complete joke at what
they were trying to do
it's basically Resident Evil combined
with underworld and blade but not blade
one and two blade Trinity so guys if
you've seen I Frankenstein I don't
recommend it let me know what you
thought of it below
and as always thanks so much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck with the
heist